[MUSIC PLAYING]
Today we're going to focus
on what's called a one
pager, or an executive summary.
Something that you
send to an investor
in order to get a meeting.
You've got your start up,
you're starting to raise funds,
and now you need
a snapshot of what
you do to get people
interested in calling you in.
Well, there's absolutely
no way that you're
going to be able to tell
your entire story on one
page or even two pages.
So you just want
to intrigue them.
You want to give them
just enough of the story
to get them excited about it,
to see that you have something
innovative and
new, and something
that has a market out there that
they can make some money off
of.
And then, that's
enough to call you in.
So you're not endeavoring
to get an investment out
of this piece of paper.
What you're endeavoring
to get is a meeting.
So you want to get them
just excited enough.
Well similar to a pitch, we
want to start with the pain.
You want them to understand that
there's a problem that you're
addressing, so maybe
about a paragraph--
or at the most, two-- addressing
the fact that there's a gap.
Something is not solved.
And you want to
write in language
that's very conversational,
very flowing.
You want them to
feel like they're
sitting in a room with you and
you're describing it to them.
Not a lot of technical speak,
not a lot of very high language
and big words.
That does the
opposite of impress.
That kind of depresses.
So get them understanding
that there's a pain
and get them to feel that pain.
Now, it's always nice to write
a little headline about the pain
and about the solution.
So if they're just scanning
the page, they can kind of see,
oh, here's a one liner
that describes it.
And then they dig down and read.
Now, you want to be able to
explain your startup first
in one line.
We do X for Y by Z, which
would be your secret sauce.
Now when we say
secret sauce, we mean
something that's just
unique to you, something
that you do that others
don't, your secret weapon.
Something that really will set
you apart and get them excited.
Then you can move on to
features and benefits.
You don't want to give
any more than seven
or any less than five.
You want them to
see that there's
some exciting things
happening there,
but you don't want
to just run off
an endless list of features.
You want to really give
them the exciting bits that
make them see that there's
a real need for this.
Next thing you
want to talk about
is your current
status and traction.
What phase are you at
of your development?
Are you in alpha, do you have
a working prototype, beta,
paying customers,
making any money?
They really need to know where
you're at in your process.
Do you have any IP
or patentability?
Have you filed a patent?
Do you have a patent pending?
These are very important
things for them to know.
Have you gotten any
funding up until now?
These are all questions
you'll be asked.
So basically, we're thinking of
their questions ahead of time
and answering them
on the one pager.
Now that they got what
you do and they're
kind of getting excited
about the features,
what's the next question
they want to know?
How big is the market and is
there really an opportunity?
So in the addressable
market section
you want to talk
about big numbers.
How big is your market?
How many users are there?
What's the value?
How much have people spent
on related items or related
products and services, showing
that you truly have a market?
Then we want to talk about
how you'll enter that market,
or your go to market strategies.
So how are you
going to get users?
It could be your end users or
could be your distributors.
So will you have distribution
channels, people that actually
will resell your items?
Will you have
strategic partnerships
with big organizations
that maybe
will help you get the word out?
Will you just take out
ads on social campaigns,
or maybe talk to
bloggers, blog yourself?
There's a lot of different
ways to get there.
So you want to examine the
strategies that are out there
and think of the
top three or four
that really will make
sense and work for you.
Now comes the money time.
The business model
or business models.
How are you going to make money?
Again it might seem a
little bit silly or funny
at the beginning of
a start up to say,
well, here's how exactly
we're going to make money,
when you might not even
have a product yet.
And that's OK.
Investors understand
that that's probably
going to be the thing
that shifts the most.
But you want to
give them a clue.
You want to give them an
idea, an inkling, that you
know what you're talking about.
So what business model
works best for you
is it a freemium model?
Are their premium services
that you'll be selling?
Another really important piece
that you want to talk about
are your competitors.
Now on a one pager,
the best thing to do
is try to divide
your competitors
into different types--
maybe three or four types--
where you might
belong to one of them.
And talk about the big players--
maybe the top three big players
in each.
You want to talk about what
this competitor type does,
and what they're lacking
that you actually
bring to the table.
Of course we want to
talk about the team.
Now unfortunately, on a
one pager or a two pager,
there's not enough room to
put in everybody's resumes.
So you want to give two or
three bullet points on each team
member that shows their
core competencies, that
shows their biggest
strengths and skills.
And finally-- probably
the most important part--
funding requirements,
or "the ask."
How much money are
you seeking to raise?
And don't do ranges.
Investors want to know
how much you're raising.
So you might change it
from investor to investor,
but go ahead and
decide on a sum.
And then at the end you can
write your objective statement.
This will bring us to 18
months and break even,
or cash flow positive.
Because they want to see
how long this will last
and if you're actually going
to be making money, or you're
going to need to seek a
bigger investment later on.
So there you have it.
Now, as a little bonus, I like
to add in a little section
I call key investment
merits, or why us, why now.
On the front page you want to
put on your top five or six
bullets that you make you
an attractive investment
opportunity.
Pull out the highlights
so that they really
see what's special about you.
Now, it might be the last
thing that you write,
but you want it to
be the first thing
that they see because
it really will call them
into reading your document.
Oh, and of course, don't forget
your contact information.
Choose one point of
contact, probably the CEO.
Put your phone number, your
email-- put a full phone number
if you want people
from other countries
to be able to call you-- and
the best place to reach you,
your company name, and
where you're located.
If you have several offices
you can write that as well.
So there you have it.
There's the content.
[MUSIC PLAYING]